essayons de comprendre la situation on a
une voiture
qui est dessiné de façon un peu
abstraite
qui se déplacent vers nous à la vitesse
v donc nous on est ici un observateur et
l'idée c'est que la voiture va nous
envoyer des ondes sonores qui se propage
dans l'air à la vitesse c'est
donc cesser la vitesse du son ici et on
se place dans le référentiel de l'air
c'est à dire que l'observateur peut être
en mouvement
par rapport à l'air on va appeler sa
vitesse vo ou un plomb l'a eue ce sera
plus simple on va plus la vitesse de
l'observateur u et la vitesse de la
voiture v alors si la voiture se déplace
dans l'autre sens si elle s'éloigne donc
si la flèche et vers la gauche on va
simplement dire que la vitesse est
négative que v est négatif pareil pour
l'observateur si l'observateur se
déplace vers la droite hu est positif si
l'observateur se déplace vers la gauche
hu sera négatif
donc maintenant qu'on a ces conventions
là on va essayer de décrire les ondes
d'une façon plus simple au lieu de
d'imaginer des front d'onde comme ça
successifs on va imaginer simplement une
petite bille que la voiture envoie débit
successives qui se déplacent tout à la
vitesse c
est que ces billes on les reçoit en tant
qu'observateur et ce qui compte ce que
l'on va essayer de mesurer c est bien la
fréquence à laquelle on reçoit ses
billes c'est à dire le nombre de big on
reçoit par seconde
en connaissant donc par rapport à la
fréquence d'émission des billes c'est à
dire par rapport aux nombres de bi que
la voiture émet chaque seconde
alors ici on va appeler f e la fréquence
d'émission débit donc pour savoir
combien de bi la voiture émet chaque
seconde et on va appeler
footafrica365 à dire combien de bill
observateurs reçoit chaque seconde alors
bien entendu l'on parle avec débit c'est
une analogie
cette analogie en fait va nous permettre
de comprendre comment la fréquence d'une
onde est affectée par le mouvement de la
source et du récepteur est ainsi de
savoir si le l'observateur en temps une
note donc s'il écoute le son de la
voiture pour savoir s'il entend une note
plus gaie av si la fréquence est plus
faible ou une note plus élevée si la
fréquence est plus plus élevé que le son
original émis par la voiture
donc maintenant qu'on a bien compris la
situation on va pouvoir commencer le
calcul alors imaginons qu'à 1 1 certes
un instant t égal 0
la voiture se situe à une certaine
position on voit là l'a dessiné par un
car et c'est un rectangle ce sera plus
simple donc la voiture se déplace à la
vitesse v
si bien qu'à un instant ultérieure donc
disons un certain t on va pas pour
l'instant on voit pas précisé lequel la
voiture se se situe à une position un
peu plus à droite
toujours à la vitesse v et la distance
qui a été parcouru par la voiture
cette distance s'est simplement distance
égale vitesse fois temps donc si ici on
appelle grant et ce temps ici c'est v x
grant et c'est la distance qui a été
parcouru par la voiture entre l'instant
t égal zéro et l'instant t égale grant
et
imaginons qu à l'instant t égal zéro la
voiture émet une bille donc une un front
d'onde qui lui se déplace à une vitesse
plus élevée qui est la vitesse du son
c'est à l'instant t égale grant et labit
se situe plus loin et la distance que la
bille a parcouru
c'est distance égale vitesse fois tant
cette distance cesser la vitesse de la
de la bi foua grant et et labit se
dépassent le jour à vitesse c
est disons qu'à cet instant t égale
grant et la voiture émet une nouvelle
billes un nouveau front d'onde c'est le
front d'onde suivant qui lui aussi se
déplacer vite et c'est ce qui nous
intéresse c'est de connaître la distance
entre cette nouvelle billes
et cette première bille pays qui est qui
a eu le temps de se déplacer un peu vers
la droite
quelle est cette distance on voit
rapidement que cette distance cc fois tu
es moins donc c'est toute cette distance
- v x t c'est à dire que c'est la
distance parcourue par la première
grille - la distance parcourue par la
voiture donc on peut écrire ces témoins
vtt ou simplement en factories en c - v
factor de thé ça c'est la distance la
longueur entre les 2 be successives et
en fait c'est ce qu'on va appeler la
longueur d'onde
lambda on voit qu'en fait si on a deux
ondes successives cette longueur c'est
la longueur d'onde telle qu'elle est
mesurée dans le référentiel de l'air
dans lequel se propage landes
donc on a obtenu la longueur d'onde et
maintenant ce qu'on veut c'est savoir à
quelle fréquence correspond cette
longueur d'onde lorsqu'elle est reçu par
l'observateur
dans un deuxième temps on à
qui reçoit à thé égal zéro
alors c'est un autre était égale à zéro
bien entendu on on imagine qu'on repart
à une certaine origine de temps et a
sauté égal zéro là l'observateur reçoit
la première bille et la deuxième vie en
attendant est un peu plus loin elle
n'est pas encore arrivée à l'observateur
et la distance ici entre les deux lycées
lambda la longueur d'onde
les doubistes se déplace toujours à la
vitesse c'est la vitesse du son est donc
incertain instant disons grant et primes
l'observateur va recevoir la deuxième
lire
mais l'observateur bien entendu se
déplace
et donc la deuxième villa reçoit à une
certaine position un peu décalé par
rapport à la première et on a dit qu'il
se déplace à la vitesse y
est donc ce qu'on cherche c'est à savoir
combien de temps quel est ce grand et
primes c'est à dire combien de temps
s'est écoulé entre la réception de la
première bille et la réception de la
deuxième bière alors pour faire ce
calcul on va tout d'abord remarqué deux
choses
la première chose c'est que cette
distance-là
la distance entre la deuxième billes à
l'instant t galles 0 et l'observateur à
l'instant t égale grand et primes c'est
simplement la distance qui a parcouru la
deuxième en un temps t primes
et donc distance égale vitesse fois tant
la bille se déplace à la vitesse c'est
donc cette distance cc fois des primes
maintenant on sait également que cette
distance là je la note est ici ce sera
plus simple cette distance là c'est la
distance parcourue par l'observateur en
intenté prime l'observateur se dépasser
la vitesse y est donc cette fois ci
c'est ufoa des primes donc là on peut
écrire une relation on voit que lambda
plus ut prime ça donne cette longueur
totale qui essaient fois déprimant
je me déplaçais un peu
et donc on peut écrire que le disais
c'est et prime égale lambda plus eu des
primes et nous ce qui nous intéresse
c'est de connaître tes prime donc on
peut on peut soustraire à ut prime de
chaque côté et on obtient c'est moins
une vingtaine prime en factories ont
également da et lambda on avait déjà vu
au dessus que c'était c - v x t
voilà et donc notre équation finale elle
est ici cc - ut prime égale c'est moins
vite et
alors tu essaies la période à laquelle
sont émises les petites billes par la
voiture était prime c'est la période à
laquelle sont reçus les en fait c'est
les intervalles de temps entre deux
billes consécutive telles qu'elles sont
reçus par l'observateur
donc si on si ce qui nous intéresse
c'est la fréquence la fréquence celle
inverse de la période
c'est le nombre de billes qu'on reçoit
par unité de temps et donc là on peut
écrire que c'est moins eu / la fréquence
reçu la fréquence d'une telle qu'elle
est mesurée par l'observateur est égal à
ces - v
/ la fréquence telle qu'elle a été émise
la fréquences émises par la voiture
et donc pour finir si notre but c'est
d'obtenir l'expression de fo
pardon l'expression de fr en fonction de
la ffe on peut réécrire que fr égale
donc fr on le passe en haut en fait on
multiplie de chaque côté par fr et onu
type lip af eux et on divise par ces - v
et on obtient f e
fois c'est moins eu sûr c'est moins vrai
et ça c'est la formule classique de
l'effet doppler en une dimension pour
les ondes sonores
et en fait ça marche pour n'importe
quelle langue qui se propage dans un
milieu qui définit un référentiel bien
précis donc par exemple ici l'air qui
définit un référentiel absolue dans
lequel on peut mesurer la vitesse
d'observateurs et la vitesse de la
voiture
alors ici on peut voir rapidement que si
l'observateur ne se déplace pas si
hugues gall 0
ce terme disparaît et on a simplement
c'est sûr c'est moins v
x ffe et 6 v est positif c'est à dire
que la vitesse se rapproche de nous
alors c'est moins v est inférieure à
c'est donc c'est sûr c'est moins v est
plus grand que 1 et donc la fréquence
ici la fréquence reçu est plus grande
que fo c'est à dire que le son entendu
est plus aiguë si la voiture se
rapproche maintenant si la voiture
s'éloigne des négatifs donc c'est moins
v est plus grand que c'est donc c / c -
v est plus petit que 1 est donc cette
fréquence est plus petite que la
fréquence est mise si bien que le sont
les plus graves si la voiture s'éloigne
on entend un son qui est plus grave